Neanderthals are often depicted as
brutish cavemen
but science shows that our early
ancestors were actually quite advanced
[Music]
Neanderthals or Homo neanderthalensis
are our closest relatives in the human
family tree the species lived from about
400,000 to 40,000 years ago
and inhabited an area that stretched as
far west as Europe's Atlantic coast and
as far east as Central Asia their
habitats reached northward to modern-day
Belgium making them the first humans to
survive a cold glacial ecosystem the
North's cold environment may have
influenced Neanderthals physique their
bodies were relatively short with males
averaging five feet five inches and
females five feet one inch tall and they
were stocky with broad chests bulky
torsos and muscular limbs these
adaptations helped Neanderthals generate
and retain body heat also their noses
were large and had relatively high
bridges
this created a nasal chamber that warmed
and humidified the cold dry air they
breathe in northern regions
apart from adaptations that help
Neanderthals survive a harsh wintry
habitat the species also developed large
brains they were similar in size to
modern humans brains and were often
larger an increase in brain size may
have played a significant role in
another type of adaptation culture
culture is indicative of an intelligent
species and archaeological evidence
suggests that Neanderthals had a
relatively sophisticated culture they
built shelters made and wore clothing
and created advanced tools in fact they
were the first human species to make
tools out of bone not
stuff they also created objects that
served ornamental purposes Neanderthals
are suspected to be the first humans to
carry out the symbolic gesture of
burying their dead and adorning
gravesites with flowers Neanderthals may
have also created what may be the
world's oldest cave art which was found
in Spain despite advances in their
culture
sometime after 40,000 years ago he and
her tall's mysteriously disappeared some
scientists believe the Neanderthals were
killed or out competed by modern humans
or Homo sapiens who arrived in Europe at
around the same time as the Neanderthals
extinction however another theory
suggests that Neanderthals made it with
modern humans and were absorbed into the
humans much larger population that may
explain why most people of European or
Asian descent have one to two percent
Neanderthal genes in their DNA for more
than 150 years Neanderthals have
perplexed anthropologists the first
Neanderthal fossil specimen was
discovered in Belgium in 1829 by
Philippe Charles Schmeling however it
wasn't officially classified as
Neanderthal until decades later the
first fossil to be recognized as
Neanderthal and as an early human or
genus Homo fossil was found in 1856 by
Quora men in Germany the new species was
named neanderthalensis after the area
where the fossils were found Neander
Valley Neanderthals fossils tell us how
evolution built them to be sturdy to
survive their harsh environment but
their tools art and DNA tell us that
their resilience also involved
innovation creativity and social
behavior much like Homo sapiens today
[Music]
[Music]